Could you explain adema and what could be the cause and how to correct it?
So adema is swelling and normally you'll have adema
or swelling post in injury. So you can get adema or swelling if you spray your ankle.
What's the purpose of that? It serves a purpose. What it is is a hyper-inflammatory response. So it is
cytokines that are in the initial inflammatory response due to an injury.
So it has a purpose to summon an immune response to the area. Though in a case of an injured
body part like a sprayed ankle, it also serves the purpose to split the area. So that you can't move
this injured joint and do further harm to the damaged ligaments and tendons. So it serves to
split it so you can't move it. Add it summons an immune response. Why do I need an immune response
to a sprayed ankle? Well, it's just an injury. So your body isn't knowledgeable whether you cut
yourself and split your ankle open at the same time. But you'd have a similar response. If you
took a knife and you slit your arm by accident, you'd have an inflammatory response.
Not nearly as great as if you sprayed your wrist, but you'd have this inflammatory response.
That's the red deed. That's the increased warmth. And that inflammatory response is an initial
cytokine response that then is the immune system to attack any invaders. So if you cut yourself,
you have the ability to introduce bacteria and viruses and pathogens into your body and
you need an immediate immune response to kill those things. Other reasons why you get swelling is
you could get swelling because you have a blockage in the drainage portal. So think of your
live battery drainage system as a sewer system. So your storm sewers out on the street have a
purpose to take water after a rainstorm and the water runs down into the street and runs the storm
sewers. And that is carried to the river or wherever the storm sewers carry the water too.
And you're sitting. So same thing with your your lymphatic system. Your lymphatic system is an open
ended capillary system that drains the area because you always have immune responses. You always have
micro injuries. You are always getting rid of endotoxins which is waste. You have to always do that.
Your all your cells are undergoing metabolic activity giving out waste into the extra cellular
spaces between the cells. And then that waste is then carried into the lymphatic capillary system
where you have check valves. And then it is carried back to your venous system and then goes through
the venous system into your hopefully through your liver and your kidneys and you get rid of this stuff.
So if you have a blockage anywhere say if you have a mass that's pressing on a lymphatic
vessel then you could have swelling. So if I have you know issues with my abdominal area and it's
crushing, pressing on my iliac veins I could have swelling in my lower extremities. If I had
surgery to remove a lymph node in my axillary area now I'm going to have a decrease ability to get
rid of normal waste in my arm. So you get a demon that way. Also what you can get with cancer is
what's called a cites which is just another name for a demon that's not fully understand why a person
with cancer gets a cites that could happen in the abdominal cavity. It could happen in the lung
cavity and there's different theories on how and why a cites takes place and getting that
drained is the thing to do. So actually go in with needle and you drain that you can get a tube but have
a self-drained as well if that's a problem. But bottom line on how to correct it is you have to correct
the reason why it's stared off. You had surgery you had lymph nodes removed now you're you're
kind of at a disadvantage because it's not as easy to correct because the reason why you have the
swelling is because you basically took out the storm sewer system so now when it rains the street
you know fills up. So doing different tissue massages and different things can be helpful
but you're dealing with some other things other issues. I do know that I have multiple blog posts
on a demon how to get rid of swelling and how to help with lymphatic detoxification. So if you look
on our website and you just search lymph you'll probably see all our blog posts that I have some
I think videos and different things that you could do for swelling as well.